previously on stardom I started a
company called not vine which is a
platform to share 6.1 second looping
videos I have a rich nemesis called REO
who embarrassed me in a game of chess I
started to work on not fine and then
suddenly Aria launched refined before us
allowing people to share 5.9 second
videos alright boys we've got a launch
today we're gonna make sure we launch
before we might realize their mistake
wait who's this um something tell me
they give this to you guys thank you for
applying to University of Waterloo but
the earth beat
[Music]
yo where are you
I won't PTO chillin in LA PTO
we don't have any PTO stars only have
videos I can't afford that on your
contract you said unlimited all startup
say that we don't actually have ptl's we
just say that and also who's this person
my living room
oh that's Genevieve she's my substitute
for the day what substitute you're not a
great school teacher you can't just have
substitutes we're rid of the launch and
your ala DL age who need you you can't
just bring some random shitty eating
your belly to substrate
you must be Genevieve you know we're
very happy to have you here and you have
19
hmm
[Music]
counter spaces Tom's got my vim turns
them into four spaces reactor annular
react
hands down Macintosh or horse mackerel
or Granny Smith uh then I guess granny's
wrong Honey Crisp apples already only a
blue sheep okay granny I didn't know was
it anyways what's your expertise well my
data engineer by trade so I can set up
your whole data infrastructure from lock
them to warehousing and how would you do
that well first I develop a custom
logging agent that delivers all event
logs to kepta delivering both into s3
for long term cold storage and redshift
sowed Romo can use sequel at the post
data since he doesn't actually know how
to code I know I'm cold
sure then to scale will have to store
these data on clusters so I'll you spark
to run all the jobs we need but I doubt
we'll need that since you guys have no
users but we will I mean we are deleting
six point one second looping video
platform
[Music]
alright team so it's important to let
our new member feel like part of the
team so we're gonna do a quick
icebreaker two truths and one lie so who
wants to go first let's go
I I got this so first one two plus two
equals four oh my god I was to Waterloo
is better than Harvard and Microsoft is
a reputable tech company all right cool
Cammy Hansen okay so yeah my superhot
girlfriend
won the university medal before she got
hired at Google she's a part-time model
and she's the one who came up with
Tesla's before he'll on musk but lost it
because of a patent lawsuit so as a CEO
of the company you know my job isn't to
be the best at everything I mean even
though I probably am my job as a CEO is
to empower all my employees to reach
their maximum potential and you know how
synergy two plus two is five and you
know how we get synergy pair programming
I got to go to that function right you
already know that's not how it's done
okay it's you as you if you don't let me
just do it yourself honestly Gemma's
code is pretty terrible I don't know if
they taught him in Microsoft but it
clearly isn't working I'm pretty much a
god at coding you know I write high
performant code that's why I always
leave only one character for my bearable
names so that you know the compiler
reads it faster Jemma's code is [ __ ]
unreadable John are you done with the
database migration no I'll get to that
after I finish this thing I kind of need
it I'm blocked by it what is this thing
that you're finishing I'm reading this
privacy policy thing that Microsoft sent
mean it looks really important oh
another one huh I guess I'll be that one
next John is very diligent man I hate
merge conflicts like I never know what
to do with them it's so complicated but
I recently learned something on the kid
that if you type this command it just
fixes everything for you and pushes your
code it's amazing
you know what the ARU don't like this
so uh what do you think about Genevieve
oh she's cool I guess I mean yeah she's
not as pretty as my really hot
girlfriend but I think she can have some
potential she peers out who the real
boss is here huh so do you finish that
data migration yet um it's still
migrating so what are we doing I
recently read a book for pickup artists
called the game I've been doing
rejection challenges to build up my
confidence I tried making Sunmi and
didn't really get me anywhere so now I'm
trying to assert dominance in the work
place to impress Jenny sir you like in
college or something no I dropped out
after my first semester it was really
worth it now I just do freelance stuff
oh yeah I feel you I never went to
college either and I applied to Harvard
they said I was a little bit too
experienced you know my girlfriend
stayed a lot of coders in the past but
she says I've got the sexiest helper
functions that she's ever seen I do some
contract work too you know Airbnb uber
you might have heard of them I got paid
a million dollars each to scale their
architecture oh yeah that's cool of
course I know Airbnb some you know our
first company got acquired by them no
what was your startup oh it was really
nothing
just some big data analytics platform it
was really just for fun you know I'm Ju
sell for 1300 mother finally oh you
fixed the bug no I meant finally this
girl finally messaging me back you'll
check her out
is she pretty Wow wait why does she
think you're gay what the hell man
don't worry my messages by the way are
you done with the data migration yet
okay so they keep talking about this
data migration thing I don't know what a
data migration is and it's kind of too
late to ask now do you know what a data
migration is
are you on tinder oh no no no that's not
mine
I have a girlfriend I swear it's not
mine hey I don't know what that is
Wow we did it good job guys good job
nice all right yeah let's launch it and
I'm cool can you also put the dashboard
all right all we got to do now is see
our users
Oh what's poppin guys thank you so much
for watching this episode I hope you
enjoyed it if you did don't forget to
Like and subscribe I know it's been like
two months it's an episode but I'm back
at it so every month we will post
another new startup episode so the next
one will be on July 1st now I have an
announcement to make
we have new merch let me show you a
couple so this one is a very very
comfortable sweatshirt oh yeah and then
also like an American Apparel stuff a
hoodie yeah and then of course if you
want to show some cleavage
we got a v-neck t-shirt ah yeah so yeah
yes all of these will be available on
Jonah's wacom right when I post this
video so yeah don't forget to check it
out it's pretty dope yeah if you want to
represent non-flying or support my
channel then definitely get one of these
apparels so yeah thank you so much
[Music]